[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to your
absolutely favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to ripping
with griffin
another live episode i gotta go live
cause i'll be busy on the weekends um
but it is what it is i like doing it
live um we're gonna be talking about
book of boba fett
episode 2
the season finale of dexter
was so good
and station 11
on hbo max i really love that show but
everybody welcome back to
[Music]
all right i'm kind of feeling kind of
feeling it today
i took some mucinex dm and
feeling good because i've been coughing
man i can't get past this little like
post nasal drip cough man it's really
bugging me but
it is what it is but
first uh let's take care of some uh
abysmals
let's take care of some abysmals
uh shout out to ritual one of our
sponsors of the show
yeah you deserve to know what you're
putting in your bodies and reachable
multivitamins are delivered to your door
every month with key ingredients your
body needs rituals offering my listeners
10 off during your first three months
visit ritual.com
griffin to start your ritual today
also shout out to helix sleep my one of
my favorite sponsors of the show take
their two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to the mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life find
your perfect mattress at helixsleep.com
all right everybody what's up uh we're
doing this live so everybody watching
live welcome to the live stream uh
everybody that's uh listening later uh
thank you for listening i really
appreciate uh all your support
and uh this weekend i will be in
michigan this weekend i'm going to be in
michigan this weekend um in the grand
rapids area
let me actually
let me actually get this right so i'm
going to be at the
park theater in holland
you know first yeah
you had a park theater in that in the
michigan area grand rapids area and then
on the 14th i will be at the creston
brewery
so check me out there 14th and 15th in
grand rapids so it's gonna be cold as
hell but we out here in these streets
back to it um
so it is what it is come check me out uh
please hit me with the likes and shares
and remember i'm also on um uh twitch
most days every single day i'm on twitch
and that's uh eric griffin gaming on
twitch
oh how come my little twitch video isn't
working well you see when you do [ __ ]
live that's what happens sometimes it
don't work i don't know why it's not
working that's kind of frustrating all
right well we got to figure that out
but anyways
um it is what it is so welcome back guys
i just wanted to tell like a little
story like man last night i was like
super sad last night um
[Music]
i was hungry and
i shouldn't have ate this but i got some
jack-in-the-box
and it's kind of like by my place
but it don't matter so i'm i pull up
into the it's late it's cold
you know and there's like an old man
with a walker
but he's like put together in a sense
what i'm saying is like he had on a
button-down shirt and it was tucked in
nice belt nice slacks good shoot like he
didn't look like a homeless guy
and he was just like you know talking to
people in the drive-through
you know and so when i pull up the lady
in the drive-through says like oh hey
that guy's lost and i was like what so
then the guy starts talking to me you
know he starts like hey
he's got like an accent i think he was
from lebanon you know and he's just like
he's just lost man
and
you know he starts talking to me says
you seem like a good person and and i go
where are you from like where do you
live and he's like and he says well i
lit i live in far away you know and
immediately i knew the dude had dementia
or something like that and he was just
lost and i was heartbroken
i didn't know what to do you know
because like what do you do and it's
cold
excuse me it's cold outside
and you know he's got this walker and a
bag i felt like he must have walked to
the store and then he just got lost you
know and he's trying to like
oh man i
i don't even want i'm gonna sit here
start crying because i was like i was
really i couldn't sleep last night
so like i me i called the police you
know i tell the guy just a second you
know hold on and i remember i was trying
to think if i i remember i had this like
jacket this old blazer in the back but i
took it out of the car i didn't have it
in the car i was going to give it to him
i didn't know what to do so i called the
police you know
and i tell them i go look there's a guy
i'd describe him i give him my name a
number and i'm like this guy needs help
i could tell he's just lost
you know what i mean and it's just like
i don't know i just i thought about my
mom you know i thought about my mom
because my mom like a couple weeks ago
my mom just put on her jacket and
started walking someplace you know she
thought she was walking to grandma's
house and then she like walked and then
like we had to call the cops and you
know she fell down and hurt her hurt
herself and
you know it's just like i'm thinking to
myself this could easily like somebody
could find my mom like this and like
what would you do i just i don't even
know if i did enough i didn't do enough
you know but it's like what are you
supposed to do you know i got home and
rachel was like well i'm glad you didn't
bring him here like what are we supposed
to do like i just didn't know what to do
man
and then like when i got to the front of
the drive-thru the lady was like
um she was like yeah you know or the
manager already called the police and
and it's been 30 minutes
you know and i'm just kind of like damn
dude i mean i'm sure they're busy with a
lot of stuff but it's just like
you know what do you do you know what i
mean
what do you do
and it's just
i just you know i don't know man
i was just like guilt-ridden all night
because i just thought to myself what
like could i have done more should i
have stayed with the guy should i have
waited should i let him sit in my car
until the cops came should i like you
know what i mean it's just like a
thousand things you think that you could
have done or should have done and it's
just
it's it's just tough out there to know
like what the right thing to do is you
know and it's just i don't know if we
ever do enough for anyone really you
know it's like when you see like you
know i saw this guy um
two days ago i'm getting off the freeway
on ramp and there's a baby carriage you
know a guy's like with his babies and
you know it's like two kids and a mom
and a dad they're they're panhandling on
the side of the road you know this guy's
got a sign he's like i'm a father and
it's just like you just go oh man dude
what are you supposed to do and i'm
sitting here in my jaguar you know what
i mean i'm sitting here in my electric
jaguar with the heat on like you know
listening to my audio book thinking like
you know
i don't have a care in the world you
know what i mean
so i you know i kept i have some i
always have like dollars or something in
my thing and i just like i hear man i
just gave them whatever money i had in
the thing and it's like even that
gesture is like what is that four
dollars gonna do for that family you
know is it just for me to feel better
you know what i mean i don't know
so
anyways
so that was like a sad situation you
know
and then um also yeah i see somebody
else mention it in the um
the chat here you know and then bob
saget
just
just
randomly dies
65 years old
found dead in his hotel you know and you
just um
damn dude i
let me just tell you how i felt about it
when i initially heard this
excuse me goddamn just cough um
that's my fear
i gotta tell you man
as a comic
as someone that travels and goes to like
you know small cities and i'm always by
myself
that's a fear of mine that i'm just
going to die in a hotel room and i'm
going to be found by you know
the room the the cleaning lady or guy
whoever's you know and i'm just go you
know it's like comedian eric griffin you
know
montez from workaholics found dead in a
hotel it you know at whatever age i'll
be you know what i mean and i just was
like it's just like oh man i don't know
how to feel about it
you know part of me wants to be like
well the guy went out doing
the sting that he loves he's out there
traveling and spreading joy to the world
you know
and at the same time you just go damn
like you know he wasn't surrounded by
loved ones he was just by himself and
it's just i don't know it's
heart-wrenching
i just saw this guy too man i just saw
him i saw him at we did this show at the
will turn for this like military
fundraiser um
you know one of those
whatever type shows
and he
you know and every time he sees me he's
like because i don't really know him
that well i just i see him in passing at
the commie store and things like that
but you know my last interaction with
him
you know he
he had his like comedy notebook you know
and he saw him and he was like eric eric
i want to show you something you know
and he opens up his notebook and he he
he scrolls through the pages and he
finds a little entry that he wrote in
his notebook and he wrote and it said
like eric griffin is really funny it was
something like that you know like he
wrote that note to himself that he
thought i was funny
and i was like what a like he was just
that kind of guy you know what i mean it
was just like a really nice gesture and
it's like
that's a memory
i'll have of this guy that i didn't
really know that well but like that's
just like a great interaction to have
with someone so
r.i.p to bob saget and my condolences to
his family
the people that knew him and you know
it's just
it's just one of those
one of those things man it's like
life goes like that
you know and it's like you know you
that's why you you know celebrate your
own life like when i see things like
this happen so for me as a comic to
relate to someone like that so for me i
got to be like you know what i got to
make sure i cherish my time when i'm
home
with my family with my loved ones
and you know with rachel and
and then like you know when i go out on
the road make sure i'm you know having a
good time too you know
it's like
you know see the city see movies see you
know you know what i mean it's that kind
of stuff you know get go to restaurants
whatever it is like just enjoy life no
matter where you are no matter how you
do it
whatever enjoying life for you is you
know get involved step out on the
playing field and and play ball you know
what i mean so
rip
to uh that guy
um
i don't understand how
um
yeah anyways it's just an idiot in the
chat that we have to get rid of
you know and i'm doing this by myself so
you know i don't know why people
i don't know why people
i have to be
stupid
[Laughter]
you know what i mean
like i don't understand like like
people's life they have to be an idiot
but you know it is what it is
anyways y'all thanks for uh
coming out to riffin with griffin and as
i said this season of rifling with
griffin or this year we're from a
griffin i'm gonna like you know uh focus
you know more on entertainment
and along with having a few i was
supposed to have a guest this week but
then he wasn't feeling well so i had to
we had to postpone and this is the
reason why i'm doing it live now because
i already was gonna i was gonna have
somebody then it was like all the plans
fell through so it is what it is make
sure you hit the like subscribe share at
this point you know what are we like 13
minutes in and if you haven't hitting
the like what are you doing guys help a
brother out
all right so let's uh get into it man i
want to get into
some reviews and spoilers um so it is
what it is man just you know at this
point i don't know what to tell you
you know if you haven't watched the
shows or things i'm about to review i
mean it is what it is you know so it's
like either you can stop watching now
or you know what i mean or just roll
with it i'm gonna try my best not to
like totally ruin it but
you know
this is just uh what we're talking about
so
there he is mr dexter
dexter new blood the season and probably
series finale
was
whatever it was last night or friday i'm
not sure when it came out but anyway i
watched it last night
and excuse me i
absolutely loved it so first let me
start by going back i don't know if you
know about dexter but dexter is a serial
killer
and
dexter
saw his mother
tragically murdered in a violent way it
affected him
so he has the thing you know so they say
serial killers are made are they born
who knows but in this show in this world
dexter was
created because he saw this terrible
tragedy his adopted father recognized
that
dexter has a dark passenger as he calls
it a dark side to him
and
he could tell that this kid is going to
be a killer so he decides what are we
supposed to do lock the kid away or he
so he teaches them a code he teaches
them a code louis brown thanks for being
a new member
of youtube so he teaches them a new code
and
the code is only kill people who deserve
it
so cut to later in life now dexter works
for the miami
he a pd but he's like a foreign a blood
forensics specialist
and he uses his position in the police
department
to
as a way to
investigate
murderers killers
child rapist that this kind of stuff so
he finds people who slip through the
cracks who
get away with murder and he takes care
of it he murders them he became what
what they titled the bay harbor butcher
because he murdered hundreds of like
criminals and like tied up their bodies
in bags and threw him into the bay
so
you know and then the dexter for like
nine seasons or i don't know how many
seasons the original series was
but it went like eight or nine seasons
and it was like it was really great i
really enjoyed dexter
originally i think the series went like
two or three seasons too long because it
started to meander and that's what a lot
of people had an issue with
so at the end of the when they finally
ended the series
dexter
[Music]
like fakes his death and he he's gone
you know he leaves he fakes his death he
doesn't get caught
a lot of people die that probably
shouldn't have died and that's what
happened
you know so that's what um
that's what happens to dexter so
now cut to it's like almost
nine years later
since the show actually has been off the
air
and they decided to do
a new season
which now that i see this season unfold
i feel like this is the final season
that they always wanted to have
you know and that's just how so you open
up on dexter new blood and he's now
joe burrow or joe not joe burrow joe
something his name he's changed his name
i don't know why i say joe burrow i'm
thinking of the quarterback but um
he's now changed his name
and he lives
like you know
he lives in this little town called iron
lake so it's like some little small town
i'm not sure where it is uh in relation
to anything but it's out in it's in the
middle of nowhere and it's very snowy
it's next to an indian reservation and
he's now just like this you know regular
joe really you know and he's like he
hasn't killed in 10 years and on the
show
he's like talking to his
sister
who is dead which you realize is his
conscious his conscience his conscience
is his dead sister who died because of
him by the way
everybody that died in the show somehow
he it's because of his actions or
inactions okay so like so his sister is
talking to him so we kind of get this
perspective of like inside his head of
how he's thinking
uh again played by his um
you know played by uh what's her name
i forgot her name let's see if we can
get her name um
is it jennifer carpenter yeah jennifer
carpenter played by deborah morgan oh no
deborah morgan is played by jennifer
carpenter so
that's um
you know and so dexter is also dating
the the town sheriff the chief of police
in this little town he's dating her you
know what i mean
and you know there's like a bunch of
there's a bunch of missing girls like
there's been like for 20 years now girls
have been missing
just disappear from this town you know
what i mean and she's got a daughter and
then so the series goes along and it's
like it's really good you know so uh
dexter
so there's like a
uh a town rich guy you know what i mean
so there's a there you know there's a
town rich guy played by clancy brown
he's one of those actors if you saw his
face you'd be like oh that guy you know
what i mean um
let me see if i can like oh that's right
let me let me do this because like come
on man why is it taking so long i don't
know why the internet isn't acting up
i was i was clicking this and then it's
like it's not working
oh here we go so play by clancy brown so
if i go here play by that guy right
there it's clancy brown if you're not if
you're just listening sorry maybe you
gotta look it up at the same time yes if
you see his face you'd be like oh yeah
that guy he's been so he's playing so he
plays like this town rich guy who owns
like
you know he owns like the local tech
he's just that guy you know and uh he's
got a son who's just an [ __ ] you know
and then dexter finds out that the sun
did some bad stuff
that the sun
was responsible for the death i like
some people he got away with it so this
triggers dexter's
it triggers dexter's thing you know what
i mean
it triggers his like
need to uh you know
for justice and also this this urge he
has to kill people
so obviously you know what happens there
so and so when i'm watching the series i
go oh is it going to be the same type of
thing i didn't know where they were
going with this you know what i mean
because like dexter kills this guy gets
rid of the body and then you start then
then this whole thing unfolds where
you're just like wow where are they
gonna go with it now
and you know a lot of things happen in
the thing so you know i'm gonna spoil
too much because maybe you want to watch
it maybe you don't but you know he uh
you know so he gets away with it but
he's a little sloppy so a lot of stuff
has happened he's got to cover his
tracks but then at the same time
dexter's son shows up uh dexter's son
son shows up and he was uh um played by
jack alcott he plays his son harrison
morgan now in the original series he had
this kid
the woman was killed by a serial killer
dexter killed that serial killer but he
he left
his son with
another woman who is like became the
kid's stepmother and but then the kid
shows up like yeah well she died because
dexter wrote a note saying like yo
i can't be in this kid's life
uh you know didn't say why but he's like
look i can't be in this kid's life so
and so the kid shows up like hey dad
and the kid's super resourceful because
he found him in freaking
this little weird town and so now
dexter's got to be a dad so now you have
to deal with that
and then there's something there's
something funky about the kid so the kid
got something going on and dexter sees
it and his conscience his sister keeps
like you know you know don't tell him
and so it's so like this like father-son
drama is unfolding
throughout the season and then you also
find out like i said these women who are
missing and you found out you find out
what happened to them and it's of course
there's like a terrible serial killer in
the area like a really terrible serial
killer in the area what the guy
eventually ended up doing
and so
there's this struggle between dexter and
that guy but then the chief of police
who was played by his girlf the
girlfriend she's starting to realize
something's funky going on you know what
i mean because somebody tried to like so
so his son got drugged and then dexter
tracked down the drug dealer and he
killed him you know what i mean
you know and he did that for revenge you
know but he was a little sloppy about it
and uh you know
it eventually led her to trace him back
to because she figured out who he is she
was like oh you're dexter morgan you've
been lying to me and so she tracks down
like you know so she's trying to figure
out that this guy actually might be the
bay harbor butcher and so she's smart
like that and she's also been on the
trail of like all these women who have
been missing from iron lake
and so the whole thing unfolds and you
know she figures out it's dexter
and you know
a lot of stuff happens there but you
know in the end
there's a standoff between dexter and
his son
and there's a moment where you think
like is dexter's son going to carry on
the family business
is it going to be him is he is he going
to like is this the dark passenger that
he has too
but you know and i just feel like they
ended the series very well like spoiler
alert from this point off so if you want
to turn down the volume now with the
time
but there's like a standoff where dexter
is like he's arrested and you know the
the the girlfriend knows she's like i
know you're the bay harbor butcher i
know like your old people your old uh
someone from the old series who is now
in this series was like he's coming and
he knows it was you he they think you're
dead she's like i'm putting you away
you're gonna get the death penalty
you're going away so now he he has he
escapes and you know he has to kill
someone to escape and then you know he
goes to his son and he's like we got to
go we got to get out of here i promise
you because his son is kind of like
we're doing good you know he realizes
that you know he understands why his dad
is a killer because he feels he's a
killer too but he also understands why
his dad is doing it he's like you're
doing it because you know you want to
make the world a better place but now he
sees his dad in a different light
because the dad killed someone that the
kid is kind of close to the kid knows
and he's like wait a minute you actually
didn't kill this guy
for anything good reason you did it
because you liked it you did it because
you wanted to and he's like i'm not like
you i i'm not a killer like you i'm mad
at the world because of what you did to
me because you left me and it's just
like a great moment of realizing like
you know that this kid doesn't have to
be like dexter that he could change his
situation maybe who knows but then it's
like this great moment of just standoff
and dexter's sitting near like and the
kid is like you know you got to turn
yourself in you know
he's like you got to turn yourself in
and then like
uh you know the destroyer's like
what you know maybe you're right and
then he like he looks at his son and he
realizes what he's done you know and and
he's trying to he goes well you don't
have to come with me and then dexter's
like all right you don't have to come
with me but i got to get out of here and
then the son has a rifle and he picks up
the rifle and he's like no you can't
leave you know and then he's like you
know then they had this standoff and
then dexter just realizes he was like
man i i'm a monster
you know and he looks at his kid and
he's like i don't want my kid to be like
me my kid can actually stop this
you know
and
his son shoots him
spoiler alert
i told you earlier his son
shoots him
and
i mean
it was like
i would
let me tell you how it made me feel
see
when a show is about someone
regardless of who they are good or bad
person
they're the hero of the story so you
watch it and you go you kind of
empathize with this person even though
they've done these horrible things and
dexter did some really horrible things
he needed to die man you know like i
realized looking back this is the actual
ending of the series that we needed
dexter can't get away this [ __ ]
is a killer you know what i'm saying
like regardless of his intentions or why
he did it he's still a killer
and
it was like very poetic
i thought it was poetic
uh i thought it was well done i thought
it was 10 years too late but you know it
is what it is i'm glad they did it i'm
glad we live in a world where people be
like you know what we didn't do that
right let's can we do it again let's fix
this let's do a little mini series 10
episodes and then like get rid of dexter
the way we should have a long time ago
and i think they did i thought it was
well done
i thought it was just
um
you know
because like what more can they do with
the series it was just gonna be dexter
you know
once again like you know covering up his
tracks and killing bad people you know
what what can you do with that it was
like
excuse me it was time to deal with
who dexter is in the wrongs that he's
done and i think they did a really great
job of it
um you know they did a really great job
of it and so who knows i don't know if
they're going to continue the series
maybe they're going to follow harrison
now or something but i don't know if
that's interesting i think this is like
one of those times where you like you
put a series to bed well you know like
like let this one go off into the sunset
and
this was good so that's uh my dexter
review
um
i think it was like it was really good
and i i highly recommend you all you
know watch it you know it's on showtime
you can just catch up with it you know
or even go back and watch the old
dexter's too because the series was
great first five or six seasons of that
series was like really fun to watch so
check that out guys uh dexter
so
all right guys let's do some business
and let's get back to talking about
ritual
we deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies
and why especially when it comes to
something we take every single day you
know i take vitamins every single day
you know i need them i was vitamin d
deficient i found out i didn't have
enough b12 you know when i went to next
health and i got all these tests and so
i was like i got to get some vitamins in
my system
and you got to get the good stuff man
and ritual is the good stuff there's no
sugars gmos major allergens synthetic
fillers and artificial colorants plus
the fresh taste and delayed release
capsule design make taking your vitamins
easy
so that's the thing man a multivitamin
should contain key nutrients and that
informs your body can actually use to
help
gaps in the diet there's no shady extras
that's the thing about this place you
always know what nutrients you're taking
and where they come from that's rituals
one of a kind visible supply chain i
love that now available for women men
and teens ritual multivitamins are
scientifically scientifically developed
to help support different life stages
get key nutrients without the bs rituals
offering my listeners 10 off during your
first three months
visit ritual.com
griffin to start your ritual today
that's ritual ritual.com
griffin for 10 off during your first
three months
now let's talk about helix sleep y'all
helix sleep you know i got the helix
mattress
i got it i love it a good night's sleep
is like so important
i'm like that when every time i go to my
health place
no matter what we talk about working out
or whatever
excuse me they always ask me are you
sleeping well what's your sleep like so
sleep is uh very important uh sleeping
on a table mattress on the road all the
time like i know the difference now
because i'm in hotels all the time and
sometimes i can't even sleep properly in
the hotel can only sleep properly at
home because i got this
great mattress helix has a sleep quiz it
just takes two minutes to complete and
it matches your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress for
you i did that i'm a side sleeper so my
mattress can't be too firm because it'll
hurt
so i did the whole thing and they sent
me the mattress and i absolutely love
it
so
make sure you uh check that out because
if you're a side sleeper back stomach if
you move around all night they actually
will help you
it will help you
you know
line up to what you are your body types
all that kind of stuff it's like you
know as i always say it's like e-harmony
for your mattress it's like swiping
right on mattress tinder man so check
that out so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress and they match it to you and
you don't ever need to go into a
mattress store again helix is awesome
but you don't need to take it from me
helix was awarded number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq and
wired magazine just go to helixsleep.com
griffin take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to the customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life helix is offering up
to 200 off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
griffin
all right oh i didn't want to do that
with dexter in the background but it is
what it is all right let's get to our
next thing that we're going to review
and that is
book of boba fett episode 2
episode 2 guys
um
so
all right first i want to talk about all
of the um i got a bunch of
comments last week because i was like
but like when is this you know so a lot
of people sent messages uh to help me
out
so like mr mcgee
206 said
hey griff so the mandalorian takes place
five years after return of the jedi
and so book of boba fett bounces between
when boba went to the pit and when the
and then when he met the mandalorian so
i got a lot of messages like that uh
what this guy's name is beats work beats
work said boba fett couldn't have been
uh in the pit too long because one there
was no air down there and he would have
died he had to use one of the storm
troopers air too if if
if he was down there too long he
wouldn't have been
he'd been too weak to climb out of there
well maybe i mean you know the the the
people's
i mean you know the will to live people
do amazing things christian mcfails or
mcfalls said
think when we first saw boba fett clone
wars right he was probably 13
jumping to empire strikes back we see
him for the second time in the timeline
he had to have been the same age as han
solo so even now getting out of the
sarlacc pit he's up in age probably a
healthy bobby lee 55.
[Laughter]
so i know that i really got a lot of
great messages from people
excuse me a lot of great messages
for people that were trying to like help
me out with like when the timeline is i
don't actually think it's cleared up i
think we still
are not sure but anyways so book of boba
fett episode one i thought it was boring
and slow and i didn't like the fact that
boba fett's not like he's not a good guy
he's a he's a bounty hunter bad guy and
he's like now trying to take over uh
jabba the hutt's territory so this means
this would be like sometime after return
of the jedi job is dead he gets out of
the pit he survives he's got his crew
now and he's like he's now the new like
mob boss of
tatooine or whatever the hell they are
but i didn't necessarily like how he was
being he was portraying boba fett all
right so they do a lot of time jump
so um
episode two was a lot better episode two
was like more like the mandalorian in
the sense that like there's these great
standalone stories in the show
that you can just like even if you just
watch this one episode you get a great
story a beginning middle and
oh my god i'm so sorry about my cough
guys uh you get a good beginning middle
and end and so this was like that too so
boba fett is like you know he's with the
sand people right
um
you know he you know he's with the sand
people and like he was captured but now
he like
proved himself so now he's like this um
you know he's like sort of sort of a
part of the tribe oh there's my twitter
thing is now working so make sure you
check me out eric griffin gaming so um
yeah so now they tell the story of like
you know how the what and what's the
name of the same people i'm sure you
guys and i forget already
uh you guys
like to tell me who they are the the
whatever the
i don't forget the names of these like
creatures but you know and and they're
like they're like pretty badass you know
they're pretty good warriors and they're
trying to
you know
show him the way
and you know he's it's pretty great you
know what i mean
uh thank you janine
thank you janine everybody i got i got a
super chat so i gotta thank you
[Music]
so
um so now there's a story of like so
that these sand people are like they're
trying to just live their little like
you know
rural lives but there's like this like
train that keeps coming by and you know
they you know they keep getting into
this battle so boba fett is all like yo
we don't have to put up with this let me
show y'all how to like handle this so he
like goes and jack some speeders from
like this like bar you know these like
idiots that he beats he comes in a bar
beats up like six dudes steals their
[ __ ] and takes it back and trains them
how to ride them and like one of the
guys is already a badass you know one of
the like sand creature guys
is uh you know and he like so he's the
one that's been helped training him in
their way and how they fight with their
weapons you know what i mean so like
he's gonna train them to give back so he
like and so it's like this epic battle
of like you know
fighting these like smugglers but like i
say it's a great standalone story just
to see that like if you just saw that
you would be like oh that was a good
episode you know what i mean like if it
was an episodic you know what i mean
like here's like so it was like
i guess that was a time jump too right
so that was like before
like he he's now out of the pit uh he
was taken in by these people and this is
you know so i guess we're gonna keep
finding out the story of how boba fett
got to this point where he's now the
overlord of tatooine uh you know the the
new job of the hut and then like you
know so now and then in those in in the
show
jabba's like cousins or something they
show up you know and they're all like
that these huts are all like yo yeah you
can't just take jabba stuff and he's
like yes i can so you could tell that
there's to be like a fight between them
and then you know those those huts got
like a wookie like a badass wookie with
them so
it's going to be a standoff between boba
fett and this wookie but this was a way
better episode and it makes me still
excited for the series not that i wasn't
gonna watch the series anyway i probably
was still gonna watch it regardless but
i was disappointed by that first episode
but this episode was actually it was
good so
i like how they're telling the story i
like where it's going so we'll see
you know what i mean
just put a gummy bear on the watch just
ate a gummy bear that don't make any
sense
so
please
again if you have comments
make sure you put comments because i'm
gonna start reading the comments you
know the good ones i mean you know what
i mean of
if you have some questions or thoughts
about what's going on with my review if
i said something you're like oh you
don't want to correct this or if you
have something to say about the series
if i like it i'll read it on the episode
so yeah so well i can't wait to see
where book of boba fett is going to go
next so i'm probably going to do a
weekly one of this now i always talk
about this i got to get my patreon in
gear man i just photo photo patreon
followers i really appreciate you for
being there with me doing very little
content so i appreciate the very few
followers i have there but what i'm
gonna start doing is an extra live
episode so even though it'll be live
on youtube
to watch it again and to follow up it'll
be on patreon so if you don't catch it
live you're gonna have to watch it there
and that's how i'll do that so i'm gonna
start doing that just extra episodes
about even if it's just about one
episode of something that i watched but
andy and i've been
oh my god this cough and i've been
getting some great
suggestions from people too which i
really appreciate too like
um uh somebody suggested that i um
do like reviews of like classic movies
and stuff like that and i actually think
that's a good idea like some of my
favorite movies maybe i want to talk
about some of my favorite movies or or
do a recap of an old movie like you know
how i like to do a beginning to end
recap of a movie like i think one of the
ones i want to do is minority report
with tom cruise because i have a big
problem with that movie
but anyways
and i also see your suggestions out
there if you have a show or movie that
you're like yo i just saw this you
should watch this
i might watch it and review it you know
because there's like a lot of great
stuff
out there that
you know to watch and so you know like
i'm going i'm gonna be in michigan like
i said this weekend and there's a movie
theater right next to the hotel i'm
gonna be at so i'm gonna be going to see
whatever movies are out right now i
might go see spider-man again because it
was so good
um but anyways
book of boba fett episode two really
good i like where the series is going so
let's see like how it unfolds you know
what i mean
and then like i wonder if
the mandalorian will make an appearance
appearance
or whoever that guy is
he's a mandalorian but i forget what his
name is in this show
so we'll see uh where
where it all goes
yeah so that's my mandalorian i mean
that's my boba fett episode 2
review
all right so now i want to review a show
that i started watching um and i think
it's based off a book
and it's called
station 11.
um station 11 y'all and this this show
is
really
good
um bish i mean this show is like really
good man uh kudos to the mix so the show
stars mackenzie davis that's who that is
right there
uh i'm not sure what other stuff she's
been in let's look and see what other
stuff she's been in oh that's right she
was the terminator in the last
terminator
that's right oh she's in like blade
runner
oh she's been to some weird stuff she's
been in some good stuff and some bad
stuff
i knew i recognized her but she's super
pretty
you know
she's really captivating i like her look
you know what i mean like it's just like
and she's a i'm telling you man she is a
great actress man
i'm telling you right now she is a great
actress
so
um station 11 is based off a book
and so i'll just read this description
from imdb a post-apocalyptic saga
spanning multiple timelines telling the
stories of survivors of a devastating
flu as they attempt to rebuild and rema
re
ma reimagine the world anew while
holding on to the best of the what's
been lost
so
oh she in black mirror oh that's good
yeah she's good this chick is good man
so
this show is about again about like
there's a flu so it's kind of like you
know you're thinking about the world
right now with
um but there's like this flu
and it's like really devastating and it
just it basically wipes out the
population
and the show now what i like about
stations 11
it's not just the story but how they're
telling the story
that's what i really like about it
this is a super
stylistic artsy fartsy
show so if you're not into that this
ain't the show for you
it's on hbo max uh you have to watch it
on hbo max and it's um
again it's really the pace is slow
and there's a lot of information
and there's a lot of timelines to follow
so at first you're following this little
girl you're you're following this girl
and you kind of see how everyone's live
is in or intertwined but you may not
learn that until like later in the
season like you might see that there's a
relationship in episode one that you
don't see how it's connected to episode
six or something like that you know but
like
every performance in this show is
genuine
like every every scene is a genuine
real emotional
experience like these actors are doing
such a great job and so again
you follow this timeline of like
this flu is happening and then
you know
um
you're following these people so you're
following these actors you know and then
you see that the relationship between
the actor and this one woman and this
woman who's like this really fantastic
artist you know she writes this book
called stations 11 and it's just a book
like it's just like i can't even just i
can't even do it justice man i really
can't but this book is the basis of like
like
how it shaped these two kids
and like you know
how going into adulthood and it's like a
metaphor for like what's happening in
society and it's just like the show's
about love and loss and and survival
and
like what would you do in a situation
like this and it's just
like i can't i don't even know if you
can really describe what stations 11 is
even really about
you know what i mean like i don't know
if you can describe what this show's
about other than it's like such an
experience
it really is like sit through it man
sit through it and see if you can like
follow along and see who you are in this
so this lady what's her name um she
plays mackenzie
in the show no no i'm sorry kristen but
mackenzie davis she plays this girl who
like
you know when she was a she was a child
actor and then now and then she had to
like her you know she
she
she linked up with a with a guy
so there was like a play she was at and
she's like an understudy at this play
you know and then like the flu breaks
out and then like she can't get home so
this other guy
uh
and he's played by what's the guy's name
um
oh man i'm looking on the imdb so i can
get this right
what why don't they have him oh andy
mcqueen
yeah
i think that's his name yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he he's played he plays so
he's at the play
and like so he takes on he like looks
after this girl she's only nine years
old you know and he's like all right
where's your parents like where it
happened so he can't leave her so he
takes her
he takes her home you know and when they
get home
no one's there you know what i mean like
and so now he's like i can't just leave
this little girl on a porch
and then his sister calls him and the
sister
knows yo this flu
is serious go to the store buy as much
[ __ ] as you can and barricade yourself
in your house go go to our brother
go to our brother's place and barricade
yourself because it's going to be
devastating so he does it he goes to
like smart final with the little girl
you know and they get to his brother's
place
and then they realize
he's realizing in the midst of this that
wow
we're not gonna
survive this
you know you realize the girl's parents
are dead their sister is dead and so now
you're just following them and they keep
following that they'll be like day three
day five day 10 day 20 then they'll even
be like year 20 and that's how you know
you follow the girl and you see what the
world is like so you see how they got
there and you see what has ended up
being and i'm telling you guys it's
fantastic i think it's a masterpiece
really i'm gonna read the book
and thank you right now to michael
mantora
for your super chat um
louie brown
thank you
and all the people that are giving super
chat don't be shy i accept all super
chats
[Laughter]
so
it's um
station's 11 is like a a really good
show man
and like if you're into acting if you're
into like art if you're artsy fartsy
type you know you just want to see how
this show unfolds the creators of this
show are doing like
like an excellent job like as an actor
myself i watch the show and you just you
just appreciate all the choices like the
subtleties of the performances
and and also
how their on this story is unfolding
when the show actually ended the final
episode i was like oh man i wanted to
know more okay
yes this is live everybody we're live
we're live
um
oh yeah i did watch the sweet tooth
sweet tooth was great that's another
great show but i'll talk about that
another time for you guys in chat so you
know just give me some uh you know i
call on you to like go into the comments
right now and be like yo just tell me
the movie you say hey i saw this movie
it's about this maybe you'll like it
griff and then i might review it for the
show but
it is what it is um but as i say
make sure you check out uh stations 11
and let me know
what you think about it uh and shout out
to all these people in the show like the
the girl that's playing young kristen
matilda
lawler
she's fantastic
oh no actually and i made a mistake the
the the guy that helps her out his name
is himesh patel
himesh fatel patel
and he's doing a great job playing this
sort of cowardly character even though
he did this heroic thing
and like he does agree like everybody in
this show
is doing
a really great
job
you know
so
yeah man i don't know if anybody in the
chat is watching have watched stations
11 or if anybody has read the book
uh i don't know how you uh feel about it
but it's uh this is like a like a really
fantastic show so i i i'm looking
forward to uh reading the the book
just to see
um you know
how it is yeah i've already reviewed on
the matrix and i don't mean the comments
in this chat i'm talking about comment
on the actual video so i can go back and
look at that because i'm not gonna go
back and look at this chat
like this
so yeah
so if you have uh like i say a movie or
a tv show that you think i'd like
let me know but anyways that's station's
eleven
um i'm not going to talk too much about
it because i don't want to spoil it for
people but
like i said it's actually really hard to
spoil that show because sometimes i
don't even know what the hell it's about
like really honestly but it's just so
well done with the performances and
everything like that it is what it is
no stations 11 is on hbo max so make
sure you check it out on hbo max and by
the way um if you still have pictures
that you want to send me to be the
background when i'm doing my solo
episodes please send them you know you
can send them to my email eric eric
griffin.com or you can send them to me
on instagram
i i do check that but make sure you take
the picture like uh horizontal the
landscape so i can so we can fit in this
space
okay so make sure you uh check that out
if you want to do that you know no i've
never seen homeland that's one of those
shows people homeland's one of those
shows that people go you have to watch
this but i just can't get into another
relationships it's like i've never seen
um oh man what is the name of that show
that's like based in the 50s
50s hollywood uh
mad men like i've never watched madman
either that's another one of those shows
that i have to uh
um check out oh somebody just said they
don't have hbo max in the uk you know
what though i find that like in the uk
and ca like when i go to canada
whatever network that is in canada they
always have all the shows from every
network on that network so i think it's
different just look for it just just
search for stations 11 and you might
find it on like whatever network you
guys have there but just in the states
it's like everything's spread apart you
know showtime hbo all that kind of stuff
but i love like for instance in canada
you can watch showtime shows hbo shows
all these shows on that one network they
have there so it just depends on uh
whatever
yes i've watched altered carbon season
two was a tr an atrocity but the first
one was pretty good i never watched sons
of anarchy either that's another one
that's another one of those ones that
people go you have to watch you got yeah
you know i never watched sons of anarchy
i never watched mad men i never watched
homeland you know and i was late to uh
um
what is it
what's the what's the gangster one where
he was making drugs
and everybody keeps telling me about
finch on uh
i might have to watch that one
i might have to watch that one too so
yeah guys
yeah so i think we did it again huh
let me let me get in here i gotta cause
again i'm a one-man show right now and
wiggy's gonna come back i just i just he
just been busy then i got sick and all
this kind of stuff but it is what it is
so you know
anyways though this has been another
episode of riffin with griffin i
appreciate you guys
being here
all right ray i'm breaking bad thank you
appreciate you guys being here
appreciate you guys uh supporting the
show make sure you hit the likes please
the more likes the better
um
once again i'm gonna try to like do a
bonus episode that i'll do live on
youtube
but to re-watch it it's going to be on
patreon
for my patreon and also youtube members
patreon and youtube members so you guys
that are youtube members thanks for
being here too i appreciate that so
yeah um
again i'll be in michigan this week so
make sure you check me out i'm at the
park theater i'll be in the grand rapids
area so if you if you're in the michigan
area come out see me
and thanks for being here
as always i appreciate you
[Music]
and
you know spiffer with griffin
i'll see you later
[Music]
[Music]